CBS News chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett joins us from the nation's
capital major good morning as National
Security Advisor Bolton took very
detailed notes in real time what stood
out to you the most in this book well
the political argument is gonna be about
China because the Trump campaign has
already started attacks against former
Vice President Joe Biden presumptive
Democratic nominee is weak on China and
Bolin's revelations about the very
deeply transactional sense that
President Trump has about the direction
of his administration with China I think
will be politically damaging in the
immediate aftermath of this book other
parts of this book reinforced things
have been written by other authors but
John Bolton is not Omarosa John Bolton
is not anonymous John Bolton was a
national security adviser worked closely
with the president and all of his
national security team day after day
after day and it's worth remembering he
auditioned for this job for more than a
year on Fox News and persuaded the
President to hire him because he
believed the president really had an
America first national security foreign
policy agenda one of the things that
comes across in this book is Bolton's
estrangement from Trump after he
realized that really wasn't what the
president was most interested in
according to Bolton it was only anything
that benefited President Trump not
necessarily the United States or its
long-term national security interests as
Paula pointed out major half a dozen
news organizations already have this
book the copies have been printed what's
the point of the Justice Department
trying to block it now well in the
language of our times it's performative
it has almost no legal justification
behind it it is slapdash in its origins
because it misspells key words in the
document on this temporary restraining
order and the books already out and the
Justice Department could have done this
months and months earlier if it was
genuinely concerned about the national
security implications all of us one
other thing to keep in mind Anthony
we've got to keep this in mind right now
the Trump Justice Department is suing to
block a national security advisor john
bolton from publishing a book he says is
the truth about his interactions with
President Trump at the same time the
Justice Department is asking a federal
judge to vacate the guilty plea of
another nationals
advisor Michael Flynn who lied to the
federal government about what he did on
behalf of President Trump try to keep
that logic in mind if you can yeah
doesn't seem to be a bit of a
contradiction there major major Garrett
thanks very much Gail and the pre-orders
for the book are going through the roof
thank you both